start recording right okay so welcome
everyone to the quantum assignments
program quantum seminar so today we're
happy to have an ROC and to give the
talk so Unruh got his ph.d with Rahul
Jane in CT in Singapore and he's now a
postdoc at the IQ C in Waterloo and he's
going to tell us about some exciting
work with its hiya rod and David cost it
on some improvements to the real law for
higher dimension so yeah please feel
free to interrupt with questions at any
time and thanks yeah thanks Toma for the
introduction by the way um I hope all of
you are doing well and let's chase
strong and we'll all get through this I
meant about the talk but also
coronavirus okay so this this this talk
is going to be a work with is a work
with it I mean even and David coset here
in the talk is divided into five
sections I will pause at the end of each
section you can ask me questions right
there we now interrupt in between so
yeah let's get started
so here on the screen it's a standard
system of interacting particles so it
could be a collection of electrons or
something like that or now on lattice
structure what have gathered gathered
from much of literature is that these
systems are very important for
physicists it turns out that the
properties are something which you know
have some no officials so for instance
there is a material called graphene
which happens to have very exciting
electronic properties so this is really
interested in this study of these
systems and in fact they would like to
simulate these things now for
convenience I'm going to simplify the
structure of the lattice it was a
complicated hexagonal lattice here but
for the sake of easy drawing on pics
picture I'm just gonna make it a square
lattice here and I will assume a simple
kind of interaction without loss of
generality for convenience so I'll
assume that the blue dots on the screen
which are supposedly the particles or
qubits they interact locally for
instance here is for qubits interact
using an interaction edge a standard
practice is to choose some normalization
I'm going to assume that each of these
small H is a bounded operator between
zero and identity so which means that
the energy of each local interaction is
not to touch is no constant
now I can take the collection of all the
interaction and I can write down
Hamiltonian this is also called a local
Hamiltonian of the system
so here the local union would be a sum
over all the colored squares or plackets
which I have some this way and each of H
I J only action spins I I plus 1 J plus
1 on these four states
I'm going to zoom I'm going to label the
X direction the horizontal direction
from 1 to N minus 1 1 to N and the
vertical direction from 1 to L and so
there's the full interaction now by the
way I forgot to mention you will see
that the color of the title changes from
blue to orange to red and what it means
is that if it's a blue title just think
of it as a very simple slide if it's the
orange one is going to be mildly
technical if it gets red is going to be
quite technical so you know where to
when to switch switch the AB and go to
watch before you could be using stuff
alright so here's a manual technical
side for example I'm going to label the
ground state by this notation gate Omega
it's the eigenstate with ya don't state
is an eigen state of the Hamiltonian
with the smallest possible energy we
cannot assume for this talk it's unique
speaker gap which I will denote by gamma
is the difference between the smallest
and second smallest eigen energies this
talk is going to be about precision free
systems what this means is that each of
the introduction hij when it actually
ground stood it gives us zero which
means the ground state satisfies all the
interactions so every so it's precision
feed now in the local terms are
frustrated and it turns out that this is
something that will be useful for the
talk and I will get to this point later
as well towards the end if your name is
frustration free then you can do a
simple transformation that is you can
take your local interaction hij and you
can replace it by a projector on to the
span of this hij
does not change the ground state because
ground state continues to be the ground
state of the span as well
it changes the gap by a constant that
may depend depend on the details of hij
it may depend on the seconds in nonzero
eigenvalues of this hij but we are
assuming those things are constants so
from now I'm going to assume a free
Hamiltonian in which each of the local
interaction H is a projected
and I will take the spin yes but you
have to become one and the ground state
will be a unique constraint that's it
Omega all right so we will talk about
entangled entropy in this talk so here's
a slide on that imagine that I divide my
collection of particles into two regions
one called a one is a complement a is on
the left a continent right and the
orange line is the boundary which I
denote by partial of it I just call it
one way of it so question is what is
what is the entanglement entropy of the
reduced state of the full ground state
in the region a so there are three
things which people usually refer to
chiropody Oh first thing is known as an
aerial or behavior which states that the
entire metro P or the interview of Omega
on the region scales as the boundary of
the boundary of this region a clear
statement would be a volume law it says
that the entropy scales as boundary
square that might be I think that might
be confusing here because it's not clear
whether this also is boundary but assume
that this dimension this dimension are
quite similar to each other so by by
simple isoparametric inequality I think
this by square of the earth then clearly
the entropies at most the number of
particles in the region in and that is
that squares of the boundary square a
sub volume low behavior would be even
though entropies kills us lens will
boundary to the power some constant C
where C is strictly between 1 and 2 that
is an intermediate feature a very well a
very well known conjecture is the area
of inertia which says that the ground
states of Captain America onions which
means I'm going to take the gamma to be
a constant they satisfy an area law
across every reasonable bipartisan of
the lattice so here is one reasonable
partition if it was to draw a rectangle
here a triangle here like that so that
so that is the radial condition and
usually connect
is referred in the context of unique
ground States but it's not always
necessary also for non Unicron states
they will have made statements what is
so why is this condition interesting
well one reason one reason is that if
you take a random quantum state on on
these particles this satisfy a volume
law by a simple ordinary on so if if
your ground state satisfies an area or
sub-module behavior and this means that
the ground states are somewhat simpler
than most bottom states and there is a
hope to be able to study them with
lesser complexity then you would have if
you had no such information
all right so let me quickly go through
what is known about this condition in
one dimension the condition has been
very well studied starting from the
recovered by Hastings in 97 we showed a
bound of the form exponential in 1 over
the gap so think of when an efficient
system as the one shown in the picture
here and if you divide this this
collection of particles into any two
parts Hitchings short at the endowment
entropy in feasible scales in this way
for precision three systems which I
think I didn't mention this earlier but
I'm going to abbreviate it as FF for
precision fee systems are no other
members only they showed using a
different technique scaling of the form
a similar scaling mister which other
than one was nine later improved it to
polynomial in became one over the gap
and then later it was in any system
there's an interesting conjecture of
David in kitchen from 2016 which
proposes that the scaling for the
freshen aside scaling for the precision
free systems should be 1 over square
root of the gap instead of 1 over gap so
this statement is true for any system
any frustrated or transition free system
but they pose this condition and the
motivation behind this is that they
prove that the correlation length if you
are aware of what it is I do not talk
about it anymore
the correlation length in frustration
free system scale scales as 1 over
squared with the gap and the heuristic
or the intuition behind here a law is
that entropy should scale as the
correlation length and that's why they
have this energy this condition would
feature in the last slide again so
there's nothing to think about it for
coming in 29 States already this this
set of results have been very useful
especially in the context of
representing one emission ground States
in an efficient manner which can be used
for simulation or computation of
interesting quantities so for instance
1d array law or some variation on it
implies that gap ground states can be
approximated by a matrix products state
which is a state that looks like this in
the picture of small bond dimension
which means the number of parameters
required to describe it as small and
supports the success of the very
well-known DMRC algorithm in fact the
tools that have
developed for in these papers for it ago
have been very useful for giving
provably parlament and algorithms
program stress all right uh since this
talks about woody reclamation what is
known in two dimensions under several
assumptions the ADA law has been shown
for ground stress of token Hamiltonians
one of them Finn is that you have small
number of low energy eigenstates which
is reasonable in many cases if you have
the system of cube it's it's a spin 1/2
nearest neighbor interaction even in
this case an Airedale Omega is known
under some idiotic assumption and also
under resumption some specific heat it
turns out that if your Hamiltonian is
commuting which means that each
interaction mutually commutes then it's
easy to show of course ez is a relative
term but some knowledge about this area
you can show that Eredar holds in all
dimensions not just to do 3d alright so
I'm going to pause here for a moment
any questions what any of the results
all right so I'm going to spend one
section on describing the tools that are
available for bonding the entire
inventory for this I will need a notion
of Schmidt rank of an operator if you
recall the partitions a and a complement
of the two-dimensional lattice an
operator K is said to have a Smith R and
D if it can be decomposed as a linear
combination of product of drawbridges
weight he lives only on the hay region
is the best reason and a compliment only
lives on the right country and
throughout this talk we are going to
denote it in short by s r of care
now let's see what would the most
intuitive way to try to prove an
ideologue the visa that let's say there
was a operator a PST operated
positive-semidefinite operated expert it
K imaginary because turns out it doesn't
really exist such that this straight
this operator was very close to the
ground state in l1 not approve a smaller
epsilon and also imagine that the
Schmidt rank of this orbiter was also
very tiny then you can use a simple
leaky fence inequality and say that the
in since the information in this came as
nary between a and a compliment is very
small at most log of this small value it
turns out that up to this tiny error
even the ground state would sense fair
in you know a good upper bound on the in
trouble so this could be one way to try
building up such operators and proving
the theorem but turns out that these
operators don't exist and one has to
make a living with a vehicle condition
which is that you can only find open a
scale which is mister close the ground
state in infinity norm for a reasonable
epsilon
of course I mean I mean just being a bit
vague here when it's to be precise about
what is epsilon and what is small and so
on but for all practical purposes it
turns out that these are pictures
approximate in the grounds check in l1
normally very hard to pay hard to get
all right yeah nice question in the
third bullet in the middle where does
the
or is he the on no I was going to ask
where does the size of a how come the
size of a calmness because the
assumptions don't involve the height
this is so many qualities that you use
there yeah yeah it is the number of
particles in the it's just a it's it's
just using Ellicott friends anybody you
could prove with something like this but
this thing of it if the information here
is more than information here is and
because this slide is very cool okay
outside it should have been a blues
right anyway so the truth situation is
that you only get an approximation to
the ground state in infinity not for
example think of e to the power minus
beta H which is that approximates the
ground said only you know and one has to
make a living with something like this
and indeed in this series of works a lot
of tools were developed was to tackle
this this notion of approximation and
this is the approximation this is the
idea of approximation to the ground
space so we start with an opiate K which
approximates the ground state in
infinite not less I'm going to denote
the approximation by the symbol Delta I
will call this shrinking factor from
these books
and the Schmid Rango visibility KSD
it turns out that for precision three
systems we also have an additional
additional guarantee that K keeps the
ground state unchanged which means that
the ground state is the first one again
state of the of the of the sobriquet I'm
going to describe in a few slides how it
is what does it look like
but think of an operator K which might
exist and then let's see what can what
can be shown about this so a theorem
which I'm quoting from that one wasn't
any but but it was it appeared in some
form in Hastings for each one seven it
says that the entropy of the ground
state is upper bounded by the following
quantity where if you recall D is the
Schmidt rank of the operator K Delta is
the closeness or shrinking factor
so entropy is at most log de bello an
auditor times the minion trophy of the
ground state in the region which is
minion trophy is simply log 1 over the
largest eigen value of of this state
which is also which also is very closely
related to the closest product state
that approximates the nonce and Plus
this factor of log T this lower one is
is obvious from basic information
theoretic inequalities and this is a
very phenomenal realization that has
been known from prior works so what can
you do with this relation so one one way
is to find a nice K which is a small D
in and small Delta and to prove that the
minion trophy is small as well that's
one approach that was taken testings and
the second approach is to observe is
that if this Factory is small then you
can do a kind of bootstrapping in this
equation and there's no observation
listen important observations from this
word which I will use in the rest of the
talk or most attending is that if a
relation like this for words or more
precisely coding from these authors if
DN data is less than half which they
refer to as the AG SP condition then
what happens is that you can use this
relation to say that the minion drop is
more and then you use it again to say
that the entropy must be small too and
that shows that the entropy should be at
most constant times
so I hope this this slide is prickly I
mean I won't go into describing this
thing you should refer to this one for
that but this is up short of this line
of argument that you find in pocket okay
with Schmid rank is T shrinking is Delta
and they are relatively you know diandra
does this in half and then you get a
guarantee on the entropy alright so
these books also observed that it's a
nice idea to construct the SPK as a
polynomial of the Hamiltonian so this
should give an idea of what is network
you can think of the ground state as a
function of a Hamiltonian so define a
function f ground which takes a value 1
whenever the input X is 0 and it takes a
value 0 otherwise so if you just feed in
the Hamiltonian to this this function
you will what comes out in the ground
state and then the great thing about
approximating this function using tools
from approximations here so here's a
slide which explains how would you use a
polynomial of the Hamiltonian and try to
satisfy the a JSP condition and here's
what go so imagine that this polynomial
K of H has a degree D so what's the
utility of having a polynomial is the
following that you expect that if your
operator is a polynomial then X sweet
rent should be small it should be
something like exponential in B let's
get any get an intuition for that so
expand your column you know at a
multinomial for instance at 7
let us say these terms come d x that's
degree and also notice that these
operators act on a vertical direction
which is the cut the partition is
between 1 to 7 then hit with a 2 n so
because these terms appear d times each
of them would increase the Schmidt rank
would have a sweet rank constant and D
of them would have Schmidt on e to the
power a degree so from this you can
you can kind of infer roughly that the
Schmidt rank of polynomial of degree D
should scale as exponential in the
degree and you already have some
guaranteed Delta on the shrinking
parameter it's needed for -
and then you want to use these two
parameters and try to prove a theorem so
you need the Delta D is less than Delta
less than 100 the base kind of
translates to saying that the degree
should be less than the parameter s here
so if this was true then you would have
this property that the a JSP condition
would be satisfied and you would have
some bond and the entropy but turns out
that from the study of pollen s it's
very hard to satisfy this condition as
it is so one has to do the removals and
this was already done in in by these
authors and this is going to be a
technical side so I will finish study
here and there and the way to satisfy
the HSV condition using polymers goes
goes in this way you look at you look at
your lattice you look at your cut which
is the orange line over here and you
choose a certain region of the lattice
which is close to the curd so here I'm
picking up these T columns around the
[ __ ] ordered by partition and I'm
totally ignoring everything beyond it
all the light blues particles would
rotate node and boundary is just this
length so the idea is to construct a
family of HTS peas which are polynomials
of the Hamiltonian with Katie these
edges this will be a degree DP
polynomial which a degree D will be big
t polynomial in the dark blue reason by
the way ecology policies for choosing B
and T in the slide and in the future
slides it's a bit confusing I guess
whenever there's a conditional CT photo
my tone is something it's made clear so
I'm going to take it 11th degree D sub T
in the dark blue region and let the
shrinking the heat is power minus some
function of s then then the upshot of
the theorem that was shown in this
version also in the later work is that
if degree D as a function of T is at
most T times the shrinking factor s of T
then the history condition is satisfied
and you obtain an area of the interval
bound or the form T times the
brilliant uh there are a lot of
assumptions then go here for instance
this polynomials have to be of certain
nice form you can't take any but I
really I will ignore those issues so
philosophically you can think of it as
instead of this stringent condition that
it should be less than this parameter s
you get a relaxed condition that B
should be less than a fairly big number
that you have you can choose x s so you
just make sure this condition is
satisfied and then the and then you get
a bound on the entropy alright so any
questions so far
given that all rumors have been entered
in the picture I will describe them in
the upcoming gaming section but I'll
pause for questions if there are any
if there is any confusion about this you
know that I mentioned
but if I'm going too fast then you get
to make entry
alright ok so let me go into discussions
about polynomials especially the
polymers that these works considered so
here's our F ground back misses the
function that when input the Hamiltonian
picks out the ground state so here's my
function and I have denoted it by this
blue line over here it's not very
continuous unfortunately it does say
that you can approximate this function
under some guarantees using chebyshev
polynomials and they do the following
the chebyshev polynomial is going to
approximate the function so the
chebyshev polynomial is this green line
over here it is going to be close to the
function value at 1 0 if I take some
values here but because very interested
in the Hamiltonian from the point of gap
gamma all the way to the region T times
Delta which is the blue region over here
I've totally ignored these spins there's
a lot of details here as well which
again these words turned up but there
are ways to get around not thinking
about these reasons reasons so in there
in the zone from a gap of the
Hamiltonian all the way to the register
value T times for T times the boundary
of a this function stay is small
so it's clear that this function
approximates this F ground function in
the in the region of interest but
whatever region is given by the whatever
energy scale is given by the Hamiltonian
it turns out that these cherishes
Parliament's for a given degree but also
the best Parliament's you can hope for
which achieve this guarantee soon off
from this slide to the 39th slide I'm
going to assume that gamma is a constant
just to not keep it around think of
gamma is 1 or 2 1 or 3 so the gap is a
constant so I you want the chip shape
follow me to approximate this function
by staying very small in this sum
constant all the way to is not right so
I still get just one question
yeah why is it enough to be small only
up to teeth that I was the boundary why
don't you need to go up to the norm of
the Hamiltonian right so it turns out
that again it follows from these words
that you can write a new Hamiltonian
which is only effective in this region
and it's non the contribution to the
norm from outside is very small
there's a bit of massaging one has to do
so effort for the kind of coming all the
slides pretty much let us assume that
think of the Hamiltonian is only living
in this region of course yeah so we'll
think of it as going from the cap all
the way to the effective let's say
effective not just within minutes
effective known he tends the mantra all
right so let's try to see what
guarantees we get to the chebyshev
polynomial PK today at that degree of
this polynomial is square root of the of
the non effective norm that's T times
the boundary for a constant shrinking
that is reputable this is a very
analogous to what happens in global
search which can solve the and function
between 10 queries just a clarification
here that I'll talk about a switch
between the North the range of the
energies of the Hamiltonian and the hand
function quite a bit but they are
equivalent due to what is known as the
symmetrization method which means that
the function that global search creates
for solving the end that is a symmetric
function and hence you can you it's
symmetric polynomial hence you can view
it as a function of that polynomial the
Hamiltonian which counts a Hemingway
of the ship all right so chefs apollomon
visas guarantee that's the degree is
root of the victim nor that's three
times the boundary length and a sponsor
let's plug it into the condition that I
mentioned earlier that D is less than T
times third bondrée D times the SD so if
this is true then I get a guarantee like
this so let expect things in and it
turns out that if you just evaluate from
here the value of T for which this
condition is satisfied then you find
quite easily that T should be pretty
large T should be the level boundary
itself are you going to plug it in here
and then you just get a volume knob and
its boundary squared as the guarantee on
the in trouble so this is still the
trivial one what do you know
the nice thing about this is that any
improvement to the behavior of Jephunneh
would give you a support which is which
for this what we'll do
and at this point was already observed
in the previous works but okay this is
this is unfortunate that we still got a
volume nor behavior with a good
polynomial exhibition but there's
something seems very strange about this
what's change is that this line of
argument continues to give a volume law
even for the commuting case when all the
terms are commuting but I mentioned in
one of the earlier slides that the
committing case already satisfies an
area law so what's going on is there is
it a problem of the technique or it's
some I mean you need to do something
else for committing maybe this technique
isn't work and that's where it turns out
that well I mean you can fix this issue
for the computing convenience you can
actually get in here at all but for that
you have to look into different related
family of chebyshev approximations and
this comes from the first place that I'm
aware of aware of the work is for this
bike on linear land somewhere under
Minsky they showed that if you are
interested in doing a chebyshev
approximation for integer points only
which means that instead of this life
where i was interested in the
approximation all through this real
interval I'm more interested in the
integer points then I can improve upon
the guarantees that I give in my chips
so let's see what happens oh never mind
maybe I didn't mention it earlier but
committing hamiltonians is a spectrum
because if you remember I assume that
the predictors the Hamiltonians turns at
all projectors and the commute so they
all have inspection from one to zero one
of the weight without T times the K
times the boundary which is directive so
what but what is also showed is that
from approximation to the ground
function if you only are interested in
that it is the true is better than
chebyshev and it so happens that the
shrinking factor that means e to the
power minus this st it turns out to have
the following form that is square of the
degree divided by the effective nor and
D times the boundary and this holds for
all the values of DT starting from
square root of this number who was a
victim and so it so happens
if beauty is equal to this value then
this is constant which which agrees with
what chebyshev guarantees but if you go
on if you take you to be higher then you
get improvement over church if for
people who would like to think in terms
of query complexity or then this then
just I read find out that this column
will also discovered independently by
Berman cleave he wolf in zonka in 1989
showed that the quantum carry complexity
of and function with headed epsilon
actually requires root over end over
note of spunk ways instead of this lower
notes from outside and this difference
is precisely what is captured by these
polymers and just think of one or
epsilon as st and queries as the degree
then you see this st. here it is
recovered
all right now I'm gonna spend one slide
analyzing these base polynomial and okay
let's say I'm going to set my degree to
be as large as possible so which if I
take degree to be the effective know on
T times the boundary I will get that s T
is also to density times the boundary
then I check the condition DT is less
than K times s T because these two are
basically the same this condition is
satisfied even for T equal to one but
actually some constant it won't be one
but in twenty twenty or thirty and then
when I plug it into the upper bound that
I'm making to be earlier then I get an
area over here so it recovers this line
of argument which is a variation on
Sabbath which recovers the area low
behavior for for the commuting case and
all it shows is that this line of
argument which uses polynomial
approximations it's the right way even
all the way for committing a minutes all
right
uh but there's an issue with this
construction for going to the general
case which is that the construction
heavily relies on the spectrum of the
then is only if you want to approximate
integer spectrums or not not just in
deciding it would also be a small number
of points we showed interested in
efforts making only then you get a
guarantee of this kind and then the
issue is that how do you generalize this
to the continuous spectrum that is
available for the non conveniens and
that's what we tackle in the coming
session and we'll see how to get around
the issues of continuous spectrum
alright so another pause here any
questions
all right so let me explain how can you
deal with the issue of non committing
inspection so we doing this in two ways
first report will make the improved
chebyshev polynomial approximation more
friendly for the non committing case and
for this will require the technology of
robust fundaments expend this in the
next slide and you will use it and will
also help you deal with non
commutativity and will get then get an
improved approximation improve and this
step will require the local gap
assumption so the first step will just
be a real derivation of these
polynomials of nonlinear sieminski and
women clean people circa using a
different method which is where the
robust performance and then will proceed
from there to doing the so one you know
behave for the we do any case alright so
let me explain what these robust follow
means are consider any any boolean
function p which takes n bits and
outputs a bit and let's say the degree
of this function is B
so that there is a robust polynomial
which I'm going to denote by Rob
subscript P P is the function now what
it does is it takes real number input
and it takes any real number M real
numbers and outputs a real number and
the degree of this polynomial is twice D
and it has the following robust promise
so take any binary string X coming from
0 1 to M and let's say you corrupt the
values of these X by some real number
let's say you instead of X you are
looking at expressives from 1 and so on
which is a real it's a really mission
and think of epsilon has some smaller
constant minus 1 now if you feed this
corrupted input to the robust polynomial
itself and power P it turns out that
this polynomial stays very close to the
original value at X 1 to xn up to this
tiny error of through the Bauman's the
degree so so as you notice here that
whatever you whatever corruption you do
to this value is X I you stay close to
the origin polynomial and we just wish
that all the quality the systems be like
this would essentially have an approach
so it's just close to the uncorrupted
value and what's interesting about this
polynomial construction is that as the
degree increases you get a better and
better approximation so notice that the
approximation gets better with the
degree higher the D here is much better
actually the construction is quite
intuitive for the special case of and
function which are used in becoming
slaves but but unfortunately I won't
have time to discuss that but yeah but
this is deftly what happens let me
mention that this was inspired by some
questions in quantum query complexity
about composing bounded headed quantum
algorithms so so first off was inspired
by somebody's it's called an aerial
photos for illumination for this
conference
alright so I'm going to spare to read
slides explaining how do you get the
improved chebyshev approximation are
using the robust polynomials now I'm
going to do it for the and function of
course because chebyshev polynomial
proximately the end function as I
mentioned bias metallization so for the
convenience of retinal presentation I am
going to consider these black dots which
are independent variables or independent
variables which is going to be input
into this end but I'll arrange them in
this funny fashion just to make things
compatible for the discussion on local
Hammond organ in 2d but you don't have
to arrange them in this strange to be
there so think of these T times the
boundary a number of variables which
arrange like this and divide them into
several blocks P over m blocks and each
block has M times the boundary here
number of variables here so
and on all these variables is same as
taking and on these blocks terrorism of
them and taking them one together and
feeding into an end of all these guys is
just a simple compulsion of hand
now what I can do is that now the plan
is to construct a approximation for this
big end I'll do it in two steps
first I will approximate all these inner
ends which is the function inside by a
chebyshev polynomial Q with a constant
area and the degree will be square root
of the number of bits inside number of
valence M times I want really that's
variables so I do the approximation and
then I will get the full polynomial for
this and function by using the robust
robust function of first off let me say
I will take the cube take the M copies
of Q I will feed then inside the robust
and on your M variables and this will be
my polynomial for this
so the next let's let's analyze the
behavior of this follow me so let's look
at what is that degree so degree is as I
mentioned the robust polynomial degree
is at most twice the degree of the
ordinal function so in this case and had
your degree T over N so the robust
problem is degree 2 T over ax times each
of this inner polynomial Q has degree
root over N times the 1 tree so that's
very good and this is if I wrote it this
way now what is the error in this
approximation if you recall from
previous night the robust polynomial
approximates by the error of to the
minus T the original function so through
this step you see that this n function
gets approximated by an error of 2 to
the power minus T onm with your means
precisely the number of hands or the
degree of the outer one so now let's do
a two minute analysis of this notice
that my M was a free parameter I could
have chosen anywhere between one to
atrocity so I solve this equation I get
that M has this dependence M is 40
square boundary by DT square and so on
and we plug em inside this and we find
that s T is basically what was it
produced via the improved chebyshev
since M scales between one two at masti
we also recover the constraint that the
degree has to be at least this and so
all the properties of the improved
approximation get recovery
okay so sorry for two technical sights
any questions about this yeah just to
make sure so what did you lose here so
in the end you construct a polynomial
that's strictly a better approximation
than the chebyshev for the high degree
range or if there's something that full
of high degree changes s as the degree
is larger than square root of the
effective norm or T times the mundane or
if the degree is larger than the root of
the number of variables then you get a
better approximation so you didn't lose
anywhere it really is you get the same
bounds as this the one that worked on
York integer points yes is the same
obvious pivots into the same box but
this discussion was only four so sorry
maybe I'll mention it cleared it was
only for the classical case again like I
was realizing the classical case we
search for the classical case because
because notice that this and and and
composition gives you hand only in the
class cookies
listen this is the ground spaces of
these variables for sharing but
composing them like this gives you the
full grant space only in the classical
case I will come to this point later
so this construction is only four bits
like the like a simple standard hand
function
just shown it in this manner which is
sort yeah see so it's something a bit
strange as a okay okay okay it's just
that this is really running the same
polynomial in this picture so that I'll
use it later for the corner case but is
it very simple just divide them into
small parts and then approximately is
point right so but it's not exactly
clear what this thing does that non
integer values so right right right yeah
it's this and and paying which put non
integer values is some yes so I'll
address that in the game mechanics tag
yeah okay in idiot so that's a good one
yeah so yeah so let's see what part of
this construction works for the quantum
case now so let's bring back our local
Hamiltonians Widow sitting here and
let's try to get things work so recall
the same it said as he I divided this
into these regions these are these same
regions I'll come to these red things
later so notice that if you assume the
local gap that means this block blue
blocks have a look locally at in the in
their own region then you can use the
chebyshev construction of the
hamiltonian here to make go through the
first step the second bullet point
essentially that works out that means
that approximating the ground space of
this n times the boundary a number of
qubits which ever follow me goes through
turns out the robust column is also
quite unfriendly you can feel it we
didn't do it some point variables
but the thing is that when you take
these blue ground spaces and you combine
them just by taking blue brown spaces
you don't get the fully known space
we're totally missing out the
hamiltonian terms that are living on the
boundary and this thing is not the
ground space of the photon it wouldn't
at all unlike in the classical case very
where you just I just compose this
together and I got the and or the ground
space of the all these variables
so we have to make this work we have to
take care of the fact that these red
hamiltonians are all excited and they
need to be satisfied so what we can do
is that we are exactly missing out the
ground face of fetch in this process so
what we'll do and this probably answer
is hopefully Transformus question and
what we're gonna do is that we are going
to use the cool screen DTI dilemma which
which is a byproduct of do technically
myself I won't describe in details what
that does but in our context we will
take this blue things a blue projectors
will take our little layer of easy read
projectors to cover these excited or
unsatisfied mentalness on these on these
regions and if I just take an and of
these guys or a product of these guys
the the core screen take it will damage
aren t is that I get e to the power
minus em closed fed round space on all
the qubits
and where m is the parameter that use it
now what does it tell me is that I can
repeat the same analysis that I showed
you for the onion these slides but with
this additional error of e to the power
minus M which comes from I can run
through that I won't go into those
details I hope you can trust me that I
think the maths probably and we obtain
the resented that under the local game
assumption where which I assume for this
random friendly step of approximating
these operators by the William under the
local er cap assumption the entropies
scales as the boundary to the power 5 or
3 so we recovered so we cover we recover
some aspect of this improved efficient
and isn't and you can ask how far can
this line of argument go so it turns out
that you know just just happily let's
imagine that I'm I keep getting the
improved chebyshev approximation which
was precisely what I mention right here
but I always lose this factor of e to
power minus T because any and a rough
back on the of the envelope condition
tells us that if this kind of argument
very working over then this would give
us over you know of two or three words
this is a work in progress trying to
figure this product so so effectively
what's happening is that we are trying
to construct this improve subject
elements using additional structure of
the Hamiltonian for instance I cochlea
and the fact that this in turn is a
widespread kind of local side all right
any questions at this stage I'm closing
into the discussion section
okay so let me spend two slides on the
local consumption which I made in a pure
state this assumption was also also
appears in fireworks for example of my
Caracas in Zorah of seven billion in
2016 on point I'm Louis local demo so
the question is clear that can we get
you to the local representation is it
known that we can get rid of it
so question is if the special gap is
constant then is local you have a
constant to for this problem let's look
at a helpful example which I borrowed
from bits work
following Hamiltonian which is
essentially classical so this
Hamiltonian acts on n particles and it
the first two terms of the Hamiltonian
they ask they penalize the penalize all
those basis states in which at the sent
bits of the same so they don't want 0 0
or 1 1 configuration so if I sum 0 and 0
1 0 1 or 1 0 1 0 to be fine but then you
add another term for example this is a
very tiny term of 1 over N and it only
acts for even I and then you penalize
whenever you see a 0 1 for example if
there was a 0 1 here then you would
penalize we see that for this
Hamiltonian this is the ground state
because there are no conjugative zeros
no consecutive ones and this satisfies
this term as well simply because this
only asked that for even places even an
odd places they should note 0 1 so the 1
0 here once we all right but for some
the 1 0 1 0 1 0 would not be the grounds
for this and its energy will be 2 over 3
which means the gap of this Hamiltonian
is 2 or 3 but if you look at just the
locations I equal to 2 and I equal to 3
the local gap is very small it's 1 over
3 so it does it mean that this is not
true well it turns out that if you do a
simple
nominalization of the Hamiltonian which
I already mentioned in the very
beginning that will assume this should
the case and if you rescale all these
local terms to the span of veterans then
the new Hamiltonian even has a constant
level and you don't run into this issue
so the problem we may be faced is asking
that is Italy the for air every free
Hamiltonian is there a transformation of
the kind in the previous slide that
takes you to an H prime which is a sum
of the predictors so the local gap or
get on small regions is at least the
horizontal gap 2 is over some constant
if that
that were true then we could say that
our results of words without the nagas
so we don't know about this personally
I'm not aware whether the constructions
on unnecessary undecidability of spec
you have Alcantara examples but for this
kind of transformation if someone in the
audience is aware then that they to
clarify also one one aspect of this is
that it is known that the gap itself can
be lowered water in terms of local gap
you do cannabis theorem in addition
relations so if something like the first
bullet point very little will be quite
interesting because it would show that a
local gap and the gap are related by a
volume in factor and there would in some
sense it might show for you what this
family or some of projective gap is
decidable so anyway so again I'm not
much aware of what may happen in this
direction let me mention talk about the
representation of the 2d ground state so
a recent work of Nina Branson it shows
as a follow-up whoever it shows that you
get some exponential algorithms for
preparing the locally gapped
constitutionally systems this work uses
many of the tools that were developed by
uttered then Dominic and Miss Ronnie
which I mention early sites so one
question is that is it possible to so
this this work gave up EPS is
opinionation or sometimes if I get
changed for the ground state one
question is whether you could improve it
further if you just wanted the existence
of a pets and in particularly can you
can a J's please go around the issue
which was pointed out in the work of
gaming gay and yes I said which is that
head low doesn't really imply that's an
idea sediment that that's an exciting
problem two thing about one coincidence
that I would like to end the slides with
is that if you as I mention I assume the
gap or the local gap in our case to be a
constant everywhere
so Brad Watts had a scaling of boundary
square by gap even for even if you under
detention on dope again they got the
same number our result it shows that you
get five over three by five or six and
the hope would be to get three over two
by three or four as you notice there's
an invariance being maintained here
that's this factor of boundary square by
gap gets a simultaneous improvement and
if you look into the condition of
cosseted one that the 1d scaling should
be 1 over root gap because of the
correlation and intuition
it suggests that resolving this
condition might be important for
obtaining an area in two dimensional
high dimensions so that's about it with
that I will end the slide thanks for
listening
I gotta stop thank you thanks
so we have done for questions
maybe while people think about their
questions let me just ask the question
that you asked about the undecidability
result is is that because when I
remembered I hope someone will correct
me is that they gave family of
translation in Baron Hamiltonians in 2d
I guess even in 1d after a while
switched at the spectral gap remains
small for a while and then and then some
we ops so in what sense is that okay
including in 1d I think in which senses
not a counterexample or why did you put
it as a question just because because
like is it possible to transform that
Hamiltonian into a sum of predictors so
that this behavior goes away that's the
question okay and this is not their own
G's protectors oh you know no money like
this oh you okay okay okay not right
away but and that's a specimen of
wandering as well I mean I haven't
figured out myself
yeah
I wish I think you're still muted yeah
hi hi Anurag so that I'm a great fan of
your result it's it's really um so let
me let me ask you you said something
about boundary to the 1.5 as being the
aspirational result so can you say a
little more about that and how you might
move towards that or why you think
that's that's the right place right
right so as a mission that if you do a
heuristic analysis of the way these
discs improved chebyshev polynomial is
behaving and the correction you get from
do to build Emma you seem to be getting
at that number and it seems that some
kind of a collection of observations I
guess might help there for instance that
you could analyze you could use this
construction over and over again and
improve and those things might have
working on it so gap you know you you
you you sort of say well one way you
could approach it is by just saying
maybe maybe local gap is not that
different from from big a pizza Oh
but have you tried more you know going
directly at the proof and saying well
you know instead of instead of showing
that it it's it's the same thing maybe
you know Kenny strengthen have you tried
strengthening the proof in some answer
oh we have I think there are some ideas
around for instance maybe change the
delay myself to try to get a better
better better detective little em'ly
that was a different kind of dilemma
maybe this is an observation that it is
illustrate that may be some variation
because that's quite a bit of all that
comes in because we are using a
meditative endeavor so maybe there's a
way there are variations on it but the
end nor honesty medicine have given too
much thought into it but it I end a we'd
have
oh hi yes there's a really nice talk
mugs can you comment on which sets a you
can get the sub volume off Oh a
correction of regular sets for instance
vertically want to be nice rectangles
triangles particularly the way you would
see it is that you take your region
and you try to scale try to you know
move away from it
elderly outside and inside and if your
length of the perimeter doesn't change
by too much just changes by a constant
then you're good if it's some very
complicated by maybe moving here and you
don't want change to be too strong but
do you believe the result to be true for
all sets or is it it depends on uh I
guess applications I'm not sure if he's
just believe or even have calculated it
for fractal like shapes I'm not sure
about that but yeah I'm not aware of
that so yeah that's a good question I
mean yeah it might be true for every
impossible factor like think what
factors have two longer
did you say something about dimensions
higher is that is that no no I didn't so
one point is that if one obtains a so
volume law of boundary to the power
three over two that's at the brink of
getting a 3d sub volume law any
improvement would give you three DS of
volume so currently there is nothing for
dimensions yes yes yeah so it's all this
the theorem is always like a boundary to
the power some constant and now one has
to look into a super improvement
you
you
you
other questions
if there's no more questions I'll slowly
take us offline so let me thank and wag
first for the talk
thanks a lot next week we have one all
to the world is going to talk about
coupon collector problem which is work
that at least partially came out of the
arm previous cluster that we had that
assignments summer and a half ago so
it'll be exciting to hear and so if
there's no more questions I'll take us
offline and you see you all in a week
it's doing well ok I'll take it offline
that's for the recording we can still
chat if anyone need to stay ask
questions of the recording